[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie toss a
coin to your witcher this is gonna be my
new season 2 video we got a big cast
announcement for a bunch of new
characters a whole bunch of new witchers
we found out who vesemir is going to be
and we have our first look at season 2
footage they've been filming for a while
now so we'll break it all down if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's even a
Witcher Netflix movie that's coming out
later this year separately from season
two because season two is delayed till
next year so we'll start with the
casting announcement and then I'll
breakdown the footage as we go along
because some of the casting
announcements go along with the new
footage starting with a familiar one we
have Christopher hae-joo from Game of
Thrones he played tormund Giantsbane
he's going to be playing novella and the
character from a grain of truth one of
the short stories during the last wish
they kind of did the last wish book or
at least some of that book for the
events of season 1 the story that he's
part of is a parable that's kind of like
the Beauty and the Beast where you have
a man that turns into a beast
and as part of that storyline he has a
love interest that's called Verena she's
a monster too but a very different kind
of monster she's a different type of
vampire she's a Brooks they're very
powerful type of vampires that take on
the appearance of a dark haired young
human most of the time they are female
but their natural form is a large black
bat with sharp fangs and claws
there were also one of the very few
types of vampires within the world of
The Witcher like higher vampires that
aren't affected by a sunlight so she can
walk around in daylight just fine give
me all your tormund Giantsbane bear
loving jokes if you never watch Game of
Thrones there was a long-running joke
that they brought back every once in a
while for that character where he kept
bragging that he had actually slept with
a real-life bear to survive because he
had mistook her for one of his Cubs then
started a relationship with it so now
tormund Giantsbane bear lover turns into
a creature that looks kind of like a
bear and we've come full circle but when
I say his book story is a lot like
Beauty and the Beast
it's literally like Beauty and the Beast
and because it's a relatively short
chapter within a book I'm guessing
Christopher hae-joo will only be in one
episode I don't expect him to show up a
whole bunch during season 2 number 7
there are three new characters that are
witcher's not including vesemir so cohen
is the first one he's a wisher from the
school of the Gryphon if you're not a
big book reader or you haven't played
The Witcher games the
a couple of different schools of
witcher's the school of the wolf is the
one that care more in the Geralt grew up
and was trained at the school of the
Gryphon is just one of the other ones
from a different part of the world Cohen
is one of the witcher's that's at the
school of the wolf when Geralt to bring
ciri there for training so he helps
train her in sword combat Lambert is the
next one he's one of the younger
witcher's from the school of the wolf
he's just there also while they're
helping train ciri and then s Kol is
actually a really special one he's one
of the witcher's that actually grew up
with Geralt at the school of the wolf
and went through training with him and
the trial the grasses so they've been
friends for a long long time
number six they're doing Lydia van Brett
or vork she's a sorceress who works
closely with vill go for Sh
she's kind of like his assistant in the
books I'll talk about vilgum forts in a
second too because he's obviously a very
big character in the next couple of
seasons kind of tangentially during
blood of elves which is kind of the
storyline that they're doing for the
events of season 2 but they change a lot
of stuff from the book so I'm expecting
to see Villa forts on screen a lot more
than he did appear during that book
number 5 is Francesca Findo bear she's
just a really powerful elven sorceress
we kind of met the elves a little bit
during season 1 but they're gonna be
much bigger during season 2 the books
describe her is the most beautiful woman
in the world but she's really tall
really smart in a super powerful
sorceress and as part of this special
guerrilla fighting force of elves there
is a lot of stuff that happens to her
later in the story I don't know if
they're gonna do it so I won't talk
about it too much but she gets tied up
with Emperor mirror as he sort of tries
to pull the strings and orchestrate
events on a much more global scale in
the continent number 4 this is actually
a bit of a WTF they haven't announced
riots yet who's the main antagonist of
blood of elves for the most part he's
another mage that works with Vilgax but
it's possible that they just combined
his character with K here's character
because in the books their mission is
pretty much exactly the same they're
trying to capture Syria and bring her
back it's just that K here is working
for Emperor a mirror and rience is
working for Vilgax if they don't include
him though they'll have to include some
other main antagonists so either it's
him or they're gonna up K here and he'll
be more of a threat during season 2
number 3 big WTF they finally confirm
vesemir for season 2 I mean they'd have
to include him because he is critical to
the story that they're gonna be doing
next it's just that everyone was holding
out hope for Mark Hamill after Mark
Hamill is like I have no idea who this
is but I should
definitely play this character then The
Witcher Netflix showrunner seemed like
she was gonna reach out to him so for
whatever reason I guess that casting
didn't work out Mark Hamill is not going
to be playing vesemir I'm assuming just
a scheduling conflict because he's
usually down for stuff like this the
person that's gonna be playing vesemir
is actually kim banya from killing eve
he's actually pretty good character and
that series is actually really good so
I'm excited to see what he does with the
version of the character vesemir is
still a badass but he's developed a
little bit more of a sense of humor with
age he's much wiser he's kind of a
father figure to Geralt he's featured
prominently through The Witcher 3 if you
played that game recently and he's a
huge huge character in the books but if
you played the games that you know that
vesemir is a big part of Witcher 3 in
the games take place after the timeline
of the books after the books and so I'm
assuming that however many more seasons
The Witcher Netflix series runs vesemir
will be a part of the show because they
did all the Geralt flashbacks to his
childhood when his mother left him at
Kara Moran I don't know if they have any
plans to do flashbacks for a young
version of vesemir when he was training
Geralt or if they might just de-age this
actor here if you're not a big fan of
The Witcher 3 video game or you never
played the game there's a giant cutscene
right at the beginning when you start
that game of a flashback to Kerr Moran
when Geralt is training ciri it's a
memory that Geralt is having that's a
little unreliable because some of the
characters like Tris aren't in the
memory but she was there while this was
happening while they were training ciri
but this is basically what they're gonna
be doing at the beginning of season 2
guess she prefers practice to theory hmm
time to wake up master these lessons so
boring they put you to sleep - dammit
that are taking notes on ghouls and all
goals wanted to rest my eyes if it
making her slog through that brick now
why does she took off there's a bunch of
stuff that happens after this where
Geralt has this vision of the Wild Hunt
coming in that's all getting mixed up in
his memories in the stuff that's
happening in present day so don't worry
about the Wild Hunt too much during the
Witcher season - there might be some
Easter eggs and references to them but
for the most part just the ciri training
stuff is what they're gonna be doing
when they get to care more in The
Witcher Netflix production will actually
be filming at Kerr Moran with ciri
Geralt invest Amir - the other witcher's
in the next couple of weeks so we'll
actually get some footage of that really
soon - in number one WTF right now
they're currently filming the aftermath
of the Battle of sodden Hill from The
Witcher Episode 8 finale you'll be
really happy to know that the production
designer the person that does all the
costumes said that they're going to be
changing the nilfgaardian armor
completely at some point during season 2
the reason why it looks the same in
these battle scenes here is because
season 2 episode 1 will pick up
immediately after the end of season 1
episode 8 so you just need to have some
of the original armor for continuities
sake there's a fun Easter egg here - in
our first look at yennefer and friend
gila from season 2 so they both been
captured by the elves you'll recognize
this elf he's the one that captured
Geralt and yes gear that was the episode
at the end of which yes gear came up
with the song toss a coin to your
witcher and started singing it as they
were walking away that's not how it
happened
where's your newfound respect respect
doesn't make history
toss a coin to your Witcher Oh
[Music]
so based on this first look teaser here
it just sounds like the elves are gonna
be a much bigger force during season 2
this isn't an exact scene from the books
so obviously I'm expecting them to
change some of what happened around the
Battle of sodden hill if this isn't a
completely different battle that they're
filming for these scenes that I'm
assuming that they're just gonna say
that the TV show version of the elves
were more active participants in the
Battle of sod and Hill if you're big
vesemir fan you'll also be happy to know
that The Witcher Netflix movie that's
coming out later this year was confirmed
to be the nightmare of the wolf they
said that's actually going to be about
vesemir backstory not Geralt
they haven't announced what the exact
timeline of the movie is so Geralt might
show up as a little kid at the very end
of that but I think the whole idea is is
just to explain who vesemir is character
is in a way they did not in the books
I'm very sorry uncle Youngblood craves
action I understand that but when you
fight a beast knowledge counts as much
as your silver sword at the very least
you want to be able to tell a ghoul from
an algal still you should have asked if
everyone post a reaction in the comments
below what are you most excited for in
The Witcher Netflix Season 2 if they
drop any more teasers or any more
footage I will totally do a video about
it but leave all your requests in the
comments below if you have any big
questions about The Witcher you want me
to do a video about speaking of Geralt
Henry Cavill you probably saw the
internet going crazy the past couple of
days about Henry Cavill supposedly
quote-unquote playing the new Wolverine
for the Marvel movies you can click here
to learn about what's really going on
what that craziness was all about and
click here for all my Witcher Netflix
season 2 videos thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome toss a
coin to your richer
you